te encuentras la tasa promedio de cambio
de f en el intervalo menos 4 menor o
igual que x menor o igual que 3 que es
el intervalo que siempre hemos estado
trabajando y además dice no hay un punto
c tal que menos 4 sea menor que ese
menor que 3 para el cual f prima de c s
igual a la tasa promedio de cambio
explica por qué esta afirmación no
contradice el teorema del valor medio
fascinante así que empecemos a resolver
este problema por la primera parte si se
encuentra la tasa promedio de cambio de
la función f en el intervalo menos 4
menor o igual que x-men o igual que 3 la
tasa de promedio de cambio es una muy
elegante y tal vez un poco rimbombante
pero es más ni más ni menos que la
pendiente de la recta que junta los dos
puntos extremos es decir la pendiente de
la recta que acabo de tras ser demorado
pero recuerdan que la pendiente es el
cambio del que en comparación del cambio
de x que es el cambio de x bueno pues es
7 porque es la distancia que hay de
menos 4 a menos 3 es decir de los puntos
extremos de mi intervalo 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 y
ahora cuánto va a ser el cambio en jr
pues el cambio es lo que hay de menos 1
a menos 3 es decir el cambio y cómo va
acá cómo decrece va a ser igual a menos
2 entonces la pendiente de la recta de
morado que era la pendiente de la recta
de los puntos extremos es el cambio
entre el cambio en x que esto es igual a
7 / no no no no no no perdón es al revés
no es menos 2 entre 7 entonces voy a
poner menos 2 entre 7 que el cambio en x
y así de fácil es al principio sonaba
muy difícil y tal vez un poco llamativo
sin embargo no era tan difícil como
ustedes pensaban hay otra forma de verlo
de hecho la tasa promedio de cambio
sería lo mismo que tomar el promedio de
todas las pendientes de mi recta
tangente en cada uno de los puntos dicho
de una manera formal lo que quiero es
efe prima de x pero que es la suma de
todas ellas por lo tanto voy a hacer la
integral de menos 4 a 3
de f prima de x de x y el promedio
entonces entre la cantidad de x que era
7 unidades o lo que es lo mismo
multiplicado por un séptimo ahora bien
por el teorema fundamental del cálculo
podemos cancelar la integral con la
derivada y solamente nos va a quedar la
función evaluada en los límites de
integración y todo esto dividido entre 7
y ya está tenemos otra vez lo mismo
porque 7 es el cambio en x y efe de 3 -
efe de 4 fue lo que nosotros evaluamos
esto igual al cambio in game entonces
obtenemos simple y sencillamente lo
mismo y bien con esto concluimos la
primera parte de este problema la tasa
promedio de cambio de este intervalo va
a ser menos dos séptimos ahora vamos con
la segunda parte dice no existe un punto
ce en el intervalo menos 4 menor que sea
menor que 3 para el cual f prima desee
sea igual a la tasa promedio de cambio
explica porque esto no contradice el
teorema con el teorema del valor medio
entonces vamos a recordar qué dice el
teorema del valor medio dice supongamos
que tú tienes un eje coordenada y en
este récord de nado tú tienes un
intervalo en equis entonces este es mi
intervalo y después de si el teorema del
valor medio toma usted una función
diferenciable entonces voy a tomar una
función diferenciable esta y después el
teorema del valor medio dice existe en
esta función diferenciable un punto ce
tal que la pendiente de su recta
tangente es igual a la tasa promedio de
cambio entonces la tasa promedio de
cambio la voy a dibujar aquí vamos a
hacer lo mismo que hicimos hace rato
estas metas de promedio de cambio y en
esta función tengo que encontrar puntos
c tales que la pendiente de su recta
tangente sea la misma que la tasa
promedio de cambio y de hecho aquí están
fíjense nos vamos a encontrar aquí por
ejemplo este es uno tiene una pendiente
muy parecida a la tasa promedio de
cambio aquí hay otro lo voy a pintar y
aquí hay otro más bien esos son los
puntos cuya pendiente de su recta
tangente es igual a la tasa por medio de
cambio y bueno al menos lo que nos dice
el teorema del valor medio es que existe
un punto ce para el cual su pendiente es
igual a la tasa promedio de cambio
el acertijo de esta segunda parte es
encontrar porque en esta función efe x
no existe ningún punto cuya pendiente su
recta tangente es igual a menos dos
séptimos queda mientras el promedio de
cambio y es quien se cuenta se pueden
comprobar por ustedes mismos
todas estas pendientes son positivas y
de repente cambia bruscamente la
pendiente hacer siempre sencillamente
menos 2 nunca pasa por una pendiente de
menos dos séptimos porque pasa esto
porque no se contradice el teorema del
valor medio y la respuesta es que en
este punto x igual a cero la función no
es diferenciable y el teorema del valor
medio te pide que sea diferenciable de
hecho aquí en el valor x igual a cero
recuerden que hay un gran salto un salto
de 0 a 3 en x entonces es esta la razón
por la cual mi teorema del valor medio
no se cumple y es que las hipótesis del
teorema del valor medio te pide que la
función sea diferenciable en todos los
puntos y aquí encontramos un punto donde
no es diferenciable la pendiente cambiar
bruscamente
tanto no se cumple el teorema del valor
medio la derivada toma valores positivos
y después valores muy cercanos al cero y
después da un salto brusco hasta el
valor de menos 2 y no pasa por todos los
valores intermedios que hay del 0 al
menos 2